holy [ __ ] it's over the Twilight movies
are over due to copyright reasons I
can't actually play celebration by
cooling the gang but just know it's
plain up here because they're over it's
why Light Saga Breaking Dawn Part 2 so
in the Twilight Saga Breaking Dawn Part
two Belle is a vampire their little kid
was born so she's like a little CGI kid
with CGI face for half the movie and
she's growing at a really fast and
exponential right now the Volturi are
like ah you created an immortal child
those people tear down civilizations
it's very bad news is very forbidden so
now we're gonna come and kill you Edward
and Bella alike so now they're getting
their forces together and they're
building their little vampire army now
they're gonna stop them the acting still
abysmal in this movie there are a bunch
of characters you just don't care about
it's really funny in the end credits so
like oh this person has this person this
person has that person this person as
this person in the background who
apparently has a name this person as
this person in the background who said
nothing but I guess they're relevant for
fans of the book upon all this stupid
love story [ __ ] in the whole until
killed me cuz I was despair we still
have a couple things in this movie first
of all the brawny paper towel man or
simply BPT her father played by Billy
Burke Billy Burke is a really good actor
he's in the show revolution he kills it
in that show so yeah I did brawny paper
towels awesome he's not in the movie for
much but he still remains the best actor
in this entire saga other than that
there's actually this one character who
was actually pretty cool
he's like a badass in a ladies man like
he charms chicks and kicks ass and
actually drinks human blood he's like
I'm not drinking deer blood or any of
that stupid nerf down bull [ __ ] so he's
as legit as a vampire is going to get in
this saga the fact is if the chips were
down and Bella ever had to choose
between him and that boring piece of
[ __ ] she's pledged her eternity to
boring piece of [ __ ] would lose to this
guy this guy is just way cooler and you
actually have a Throwdown in the end of
this movie I thought they were all just
going to get together and talk but
there's actually this big Throwdown that
happens and they actually push the
limits a little more than they have in
the other Twilight movies I always had
to use my imagination to see how
vampires died
like I think they ripped their limbs off
or their heads off or some [ __ ] but this
one it shows they just like pop their
heads off like corks I'm like all right
cool they finally figured out that
showing that is not a bad thing you can
tell they were like we can't just have
them get together and talk we need a
fight otherwise every guy that gets
dragged to this movie by his really
needy girlfriend is gonna be bored out
of his mind he's gonna commit suicide
this movie will lead to the death of
millions the movie still has it's absurd
like you're like stop talking like that
just one scene where Bella's like nobody
has ever left anyone northern I love you
stop it you can't qualify that [ __ ] in
the history of mankind no one has ever
really pretty sure at some time in the
Holocaust there were a few instances
where someone gave their life so someone
would remain hidden from the Nazis and
you're saying no one has ever loved
anyone more than you love this boring
[ __ ] ever really stop it when people
talk like that I just hear an 18 year
old girl who doesn't know what she
actually wants in life talking she's no
longer a vampire who crawls up cliffs
and kills Cougars now now they explained
the whole Jacob and Renesmee and him
imprinting on her and so now he's
infatuated with her kind of thing in
this movie so is it as creepy now that I
know about it as it was in the other
movies
yeah really [ __ ] absolutely he's like
look it's not like that so I'm just
infatuated with her and I want to get
married by implication and want to have
sex with her but she's not going to
mature for seven years so I'm gonna have
blue balls for a little kid for seven
years no way to make that not creepy
which is funny because the whole
implication is he was infatuated with
Bella because he was actually infatuated
with her would-be child in which case if
you were infatuated with one parent
wouldn't you be infatuated with the
other parent maybe that's why Jacob and
Edward have such tension because they
have crushes on each other and they
don't want to admit it so they're just
pulling each other's hair on the
playground or some [ __ ] that's what I'm
thinking and people are saying this is
actually a good movie is it a good movie
no is it the best Twilight movie yet yes
it is but honestly this is what it's
like
I see the Twilight movies as jail rape
cinematic sodomy the first for jail rape
incidents you're like god this is
terrible this is dis hurt and then by
the fifth one this movie you just you go
limp and you kind of just accept the
situation and you know that if you just
don't move and you don't fight it it'll
be over soon and it's grown to not her
as much I think that's this Twilight
movie so is that's why Light Saga
Breaking Dawn Part two a good movie no
it's not it's still meant for tweens and
people who are like as Reggie it could
take your shirt off while you are with
Metro boy oh yeah watch your skin stain
watch his skin sparkle that's pretty
much it so this particular chapter of
the Twilight movies seemed to focus up a
bit more it had a character with a bit
of edge to him and that actually adds a
lot to a movie and add an end fight at
the end of the movie that was actually
pretty enjoyable to watch it doesn't
make grinding through the other four and
a half movies worth it I'm saying as far
as this chapter goes I can't actually
give it a complete [ __ ] writing
because they really did try and I don't
want to compromise my integrity just for
the sake of talking [ __ ] I will say this
movies not good but you'll live through
it but you won't remember it in t-minus
15 minutes yep already forgot us it's
over the epic finale that will live
forever nope not really couple weeks in
the box office and then it will die
permanently till they remake it and then
we have to start this whole process over
again right so what is the most
laughable moment in the entire Twilight
Saga if you've seen the Twilight movies
if I if you haven't and I have spared
you from such pain awesome glad I was
here for you for the rest of you who
didn't heed my warnings and you ended up
watching the Twilight movies what is the
most laughable part of the entire saga
for you whatever it is comment below let
me know and as always if you like what
you've seen here and you want to see
more click right here to see more
you